hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation
uncovering immunological mechanisms of
protection from infection
and vaccination in humans i am susie of
labyrinths and i'll be your today's
moderator now let's get started before
we begin
i would like to remind everyone that
today's event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation
to do so simply type them in the ask a
question box
and click send we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the ask a question box at the
far left
of your screen i now present today's
speaker
dr marcelo b stein professor of
pediatrics
associate director for basic and
translational research
and immunology group leader at the
center
of vaccine excuse me a center for
vaccine development
and global health at the university of
maryland for a complete biography on dr
stein
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen dr stein you may now
begin your presentation
good morning i would like to start
by thanking the people at a flowy time
who has invited me to present
a some of the work conducted in my group
and i would like to say at the outset
that this is
a
slide presentation that will be
covering the mechanisms of protection
from infection and vaccination in
humans and a the
use of mass cytometry that
can accelerate the development of a
vaccine and the understanding of the
mechanisms of infection in humans
so to start with the general description
of the vaccine development
pipeline the development of vaccines
is a very complex enterprise involving
many many stages
including a discovery phase an
exploratory
they typically perform in animal models
all the way to the clinical stage
and those a vaccine candidates that are
deemed appropriate proceed into the
phase one and phase
two studies which are small
human studies in which many
immunological studies are performed in
an attempt to identify
the immunological correlation of
protection
that is verified during
the clinical stage state that
those the new mechanisms are
also translatable to human
and because of the limitations
on availability of cells during the
phase one and
two clinical studies particularly
studies contacted with
children and also due to the complexity
of the immune response
technologies such as a massive geometry
that allows the measurement of many many
parameters simultaneously
can have a great impact
so i will be addressing this
presentation
the how may we have a successfully used
mass cytometry
to help identify the new responses which
might vary on in protection and natural
infection
as well as during vaccination say of the
many organisms studied in my group
this talk will be focused on salmonella
tightly
and the reason why i selected this
organism
is because it's a disease of great
public health
important which causes about 17 million
cases and 200
000 annually so
i will focus on three different projects
that we perform over the last
few years in which we have used massage
geometry
to for example identify the key role
that the regulator
cells play in the development
of typhoid fever by using a unique
model in which volunteers are orally
challenged with white texture more
energy
i will then move into a
series of studies in which the cellular
new responses
are measured in both children
and adults with the end point of
comparing whether the response responses
are similar
or not and i will conclude
by a very interesting series of
experiments
in which we study the epigenetic
modifications
elicited themselves isolated from the
human
gut and exposed in vitro
to salmonella diet these experiments
are important because it
can have a great impact
in the responsive at the gut
level so the first
part of the study will be that's
referring to the regulatory cells
and just to give you a basic
understanding of a type of
fever for those of you who are not
familiar
this disease is caused by the bacterium
salmonella and terrica cerebral
typhi spray via contaminated food and
water
individuals can develop chronic and
symptomatic infections
which can spread the disease and
a cause achieving effectively others
as well as a big problem if related to
the
emergence of antibiotic receptors
as i mentioned somebody attack is a gram
negative human restricted faculty
intracellular pathogen
which makes the studies in humans
very important to understand the
pathogenesis
as well as vaccine a development
this appeal is transmitted via difficult
oral route
and after accessing the heart
it disseminates with the blood stream
into a systemic and sometimes chronic
infections
and one of the two vaccines that has
been realized
in the united states it's the oral light
attenuated vaccine
strain d21 cy21a
now over the years we understood
the immunogenicity of this vaccine
and defined the books
antibodies memory defiled
they are in use however they tend not to
correlate with the protection from human
wifi
challenge infection
also we
studied and reported that cd4 and cd8
diesel responses appear to play an
important role
both in terms of cytokine production
as well as contact dependent cycle of
system
this diagram is from a
review that i my group published
a few years ago in which we have
developed an understanding of
what the immune response salmonella
scientists entail
in humans and they include
the memory results they include
b-memory cells antibodies including
cells that means a humoral harm of the
new response
dendritic cells and
if important role of chemotherapy
cytokines
involves a deactivation of antigen
preventing cells macrophages and treated
cells
as well as a polymorpholuble cell
activation
and even by standard stimulation and
general expansion of the
anti-cell however these regulatory
sounds
remain undefined
so in spite of this
complexity of the new response to
salmonella
the key questions remains an answer
which of these
telemedicine new responses if any
are associated with protection from
typhoon zero
and why is this important the
identification of the precise
immunological correlation of protection
either mechanistic or non-mechanistic
can not only help define effector
immunity
to be pursued during vaccine development
but also help predict long-term
protection
as well as accelerate the development of
blood spectrum vaccines to other entire
fears for example those caused by
salmonella parasite pa
salmonella paratv as well as other
entire
infections like shigella or
enterotoxinic
e-coli now how can we address
this question directly and a
one way in which this can be addressed
particularly given that some of the
types here as i mentioned before it's a
human respective
pathogen if to study
volumes who are challenged with wild
type
salmonella diet and for this we
enter into a close collaboration with
antipolar
and during this human challenge
model of the many many parameters that
we have
measured we concentrate in trying to
identify the correlation of protection
and for the purposes of this stock i
will focus
on all of the cell negative immune
response studies
on the regulatory cell
this is the study design basically
volunteers where
giant with white types and monetization
and then at several times we obtained a
cell which we are used
in the present study now some of these
women here
who were challenged developed typhoid
disease
while others did not
and the approach was to compare the new
responses
that were present in volunteers
who were developed
type receivers and those volunteers who
did not by comparing and contracting
those responses
we can have a more educated
understanding of what are the newest
cultures in humans that correlate with
protection
so for this talk as i mentioned i will
concentrate in regulatory reasons
and why these cells are important is
because
they work as they counter balancing harm
of
immune response by suppressing the
response of the effect of memory itself
so with this regulation of the
regulatory reform
can have a strong impact
in what the ultimate immune response is
generated
and whether this
response stops being
protected because an over-regulation by
the regulatory cells
so the goals are those that i just
mentioned
which are to identify the potential role
of circulating regulatory
cells in a lifetime type of challenge
model is human
and second to identify which assists the
homing protection
and activation characteristics of the
regulatory results
that are associated with typhoid
diagnosis
and here if you focus a where my
mouse is indicating we can see that
even before challenge some individuals
have a regulatory response particularly
on regulatory cells that express
intervenor of 47.
which is a cat homing molecule that does
volunteer here in red
who did not develop
a typhoid disease
if we look in panel b we can see that
after challenge one to four days in this
case 21 to 28 days in this
there are lower irregulatory cells
in circulation that express alpha-4
probably indicating that b-cells
got home to the gut
here we are showing the
levels of deep regulatory activation in
the presentative volunteers
and as you can see in those questions
to develop cycling diseases in blue
the cells and the regulatory cells are
more activated that in those
who did not develop type of disease
they suggested that the the upregulation
of a state is specific
expression of some
markers particularly near the time of
typography losses
support an association of increased
activation of the regulatory cells
and the development of typhoid disease
now we went a step a further
and we perform depletion studies of the
regulatory cells
in this case we isolated peritoneum of
nuclear cells
some of them were depleted
and some of them were not depleted of
the regulatory cell
and then they were exposed to exciting
brexit autonomous
cells and after 14 to 18
hours we stained the cells for mass
cytometry
and that allowed us to measure
many parameters at the same time trying
to see whether
depletion of the regulator itself
have an effect on the effect of response
and this is what we have seen that once
we declare
the regulatory cells these are default
increase
of depleted versus boxes if we can see a
significant increase
in a cell that responded to tlf
alpha as well as those that are
a double positive and this increases
where observed both
in terms of expressing alpha orbital
seven which is an
indication that these cells are coming
to the gut
as well as alpha beta seven negative
results
so in conclusion from this section of
the talk
a type of statistic expression of
intervene alpha 4 vector 7
is a regulated pre-challenge in those
volunteers to develop type of disease
a type specific expression of activation
molecules
is increased in typhoon disease volume
here and the regulatory cells are
capable of
function and suppressing scientificity
responses are giving an indication that
their responses
will be following after following
challenges with wildlife diet
or whether they volunteer developed or
not time for disease
they
and i would like to acknowledge a
particular monika macarthur
who they perform a study in my group
as well as our collaborators and off for
statisticians while living with clinical
studies at
cbd and many many of the people involved
in this important experiment
now moving to this moving to the second
topic
i would like to discuss some of the
differences observing the different
mediated unity
elicited by uranium immunization with
the licensed eye 21a
attenuated type of river vaccine which i
described at the outset of this
presentation
but comparing the responses in children
and adults
so human pediatric immunology is
very important because the responses in
children and adults are not necessarily
the same
and there is a very good understanding
of the human pediatric immune response
and this is due to many reasons
particularly
accessibility upon the ears the
quantities of cells that we can obtain
the time points that can be studied
et cetera et cetera which makes them a
critically
underexplored population now
a massage geometry is
a one of those technologies that because
of its self-spearing characteristics
it makes the measurement of multiple
parameters
possible with a fewer number of
cells and this is particularly important
in the study of periodic populations in
which the accessibility to the number
is very limited regarding the
differences
in the literature between children and
adults it is clear that lower
percentages of cd4 are observed in
children also there is an increase in
the percentage
a lower percentage of naive season
and a higher percentage of naive island
children
and that younger children are less
likely to develop
robust immune responses so what do we
know
from the field in one of the few studies
in which
children of various ages were compared
a study that goes back into the
early 80s in children in chile
uh children which are of lower
age have a somewhat lower
response in terms of protecting efficacy
that those children that are 10 to 14
years old
or 15 year-old children and although
it's a lot of
overlap there is a trend in efficacy
here we can see 59 in the five to nine
year olds
going to 67 in the 10 to 14
and 85 in the over 15 years old
because of this the field the
data with that this guy is trying to
understand
what is the difference among
different ages strata of
children and whether which are the
differences in the responses between
physiologic and adult
recipients
and here we have some phenotypic data
okay by looking at cd4 t cells in
a six to fifteen years old
they are 16 to 17 years old they
are in orange and a adult
20 to 65 years old in black
and as you can see in the children
previously reported
we have higher percentages
of a naive cell and
a significantly lower percentages
of effective memory cells and this is
the percentages of the memory population
in this case it is four positive cells
and but this
is a just a phenotypic characterization
what
is important is how do these cells
respond to antigenic stimulation
and we use several systems but i will
focus this
thought in the use of a staphylococcal
enzyme toxin d or acv which is a super
antigen
that because it's crossing the beta
subunit
of the mhg class 2 with the tcr
it stimulates a large number of cells
and this robust activation will allow us
to compare
the what you will call the overall
disseminated immune responses in
children versus
adults if we look
at the city four levels of deactivation
as measured by
cd69 expression is a marker of general
activation
you can see the close statistical
correlation
as the children age
in contrast in the dots those
differences are not
applying the er you can see that your
point
81 showing that throughout
age the responses to scd do not change
it at all
so we identify this age-associated
increasing activation potential
among city for positive cells
in children if we look at cda
responses we see very much the same a
phenomenon the levels of activation
increase at the children age
however in adults the response
is flat
also extremely important is that we
study this
multi-functionality that is the ability
of cells to produce
more than one egg function for example
interferon gamma and infalca production
together
with il17 or other functions
and what we can see is that at the
children age there is really not much
difference when you look at multiple
functional
issues however there were very strong
correlations that is that is significant
when we look at two functions three
functions
or more than three functions in children
indicating that the children of a
younger age
seem to have a lower multi-functional
responses than those
at a let's say
over 15 years old
if we look at cdx positivity effect on
memory cell
and multi-functionality we see the same
response one function that barely
makes it significant but two functions
three functions and more than three
functions
are highly significant and increase
with data again indicating that the
functionality
of this cda a positively effective
memory
cells are strongly correlated with
age through adolescent in this case
after stimulation
with the super antigen and this is
important they reach
adult levels by the teenage
years so in summary of the
exceeding response we can see that
children
have decreased activation decreased
responses i didn't have to show you the
individual data
but this is published in this paper
infrared
immunology in 2018 in which
many cytokines are produced at a lower
levels in children
and particularly the movement
functionality
is lowering children than in adults
and a pretty much the same
the same effect over age are observed
with regard to a cd4 positive itself
and this is what i just mentioned that
16 and 17 years old is an activation and
function
are already more adult life
but one thing is to study a
a super antigen response as a general
a simulation but the much more
important thing is to study the
specifically new response in children
who have been vaccinated with cy21a
but studying the alcoholics the monetary
stimulation
response and we use a protocol similar
to what i showed before
we have the target cells in which we
gather evaluate
and let an infected compare to target
cells that follow the same procedure
but they have been infected with
salmonella typhi
and then we combine them with blc
obtained from
the gene and what we have
then is that proceeding for self
we see increases in the responses that
are significant
previous post vaccinations involve
children as indicated by the bluer
orange
symbol as well as adults
in contrast in cd8 positive cells we can
see the increases that we typically
observe
in the gulf in children in part
due to a great variability did not reach
statistically significant levels
but to study in a
further depth this responses
since we are working with a mass
cyclomat
with over 30 parameters we use a
disney which is one of the classical
dimensionality reduction towards to
study
the variation between children
and adults and the advantage of this is
that this provides an unbiased means of
identifying
key population features that will be
very difficult to deserve using
conventional
dating methods and here
i included an example of a teaching map
and you can see
the in children which is by the two
top quads as well
as adults in the two lower panels
if you look for example at a cluster
12 it is very easy to see
that they have less of the cell
representation
than attack and the same thing for a
cluster
file when we analyze this data
for example for cda possibly cd69
positive that is activated
so we can see that some
of the populations are higher in
children for example here with the blue
part
than in adults for other clusters
adults are highly they have a higher
representation in the clusters than
children
and we can see that many clusters
37 12 and 15 and 22
in a dark you see
a height of representation in those
clusters
now this is a not very relevant and less
you know what is in those clusters
so we use a gate
out of those a cluster to identify
which of the characteristics in each of
those clusters
and here we have clusters one and five
which are overrepresented in children
and the rest of the clusters which are
represent overrepresented in adult
and as you can see just by looking at
the proportions of cells
that reduce cancer feeling the free
gamma ray l2
that in a girl the response
is more multi-functional than that
observed
in children and this is probably better
exemplified
on this panel from the right corner
in which the activity model prefabs
functions in black for three functions
in dark gray they have really
concentrated
in those clusters that are over
represented
in adults and if we can
also we would we did study a
homemade molecule other notifications
one side one
cytokines other molecules
that are important in cell activation
all concomitantly so we put
the harass direction great detail
the different clusters and which
are their levels of functionality
so we to summarize this autologous part
of the presentation
in the cells were it specifically
stimulated
again we see that changes have decreased
baseline
a multi-functionality as compared to
adults
the adults have a new
enhanced activation following
the immunization with the type of
function dy21a
and very importantly in children their
fewer cells
that they exhibit multi-functional
properties
and this basically summarizes
these important findings comparing
children
and adults of which placement
functionality
appears to be a defining a
characteristic
in contrast adults tend to find higher
levels of activation
and although the responses to cy21a
vaccination it's similar in terms of the
overall response
there are important differences in the
responsiveness
at the baseline funny
for this section of the talk i would
like to
acknowledge the mark rudolph and next
psd students in my group as well
as a monika mccarthy who
performed the majority of this next time
and now we go into the third
point of discussion during this
presentation
and this has to deal with the early
cell type specific epigenetic
modification
elicited itself which were isolated
from the human blood following a
xvivo exposure to salmonella type
so these are the results of a payment
that was just published
last month in scientific reports
so this data is already available
for you to look in detail
so why to study epigenetic modifications
and these are the main reasons
the epigenetic proteins
that are elicited upon stimulation of
cells
are key molecular processes with
underlying which
underlie the differentiation of cells
throughout the maturation
process all the way from progenitors to
functionally mature
cells there are many epigenetic
modifications including a circulation
methylation phosphorylation
etc and this modification
dictate chromatin structural function
and regulate gene expression
and and in fact in certain technical
modifications have been associated with
human
disease now
the bacteria in this epigenetic changes
are simply a very little to no reports
that have studied them
in detail in human
particularly at the level of the tissues
in this case the human gut
what is important to keep in mind is
that alterations
in the accounting marks
regulate the gene expression that can
lead to either
separation or activation depending on
the particular
epigenetic modification and
the hypothesis of the present study was
like that the exposure to material
organisms will result in specific
long-lasting
impact on the home responded
and they refer to bacterial infection
here they i they borrow a graphic from
the beautiful review that they
carry in africa and collaborators
published
earlier this year in genes and they
point that at
all levels of differentiation and
activation
there is an increasing number of
epigenetic
modifications that have been described
on a problem and they include
all cells in lineage and the lymphocytes
report
healthy economic cells include
granulocytes macrophages and british
cells
and taken all together this point to the
importance
of epigenetic changes in the new
response
so to reiterate the rationale for
studying this
genetic modification intestine infection
sending an ilium with humans is the main
segment of hgi
drug in which the pathology associated
with
his basic infection has been reported
and is considered the favorite and the
favorite
site of infection for salmonella types
the vast majority of immunological
studies performance human
involved by necessity the study of
immunosuction circulation
and very little is known about the
mucosal
immune responses at the level of the gut
and he might not have been studying this
for several years
and we have reported a lot excellent
medicine near
in the human terminal healing following
ty-21a immunization
however no information is available on
the early genetic
epigenetic signature elixir itself
isolated from the human terminal
following xvi works for should be while
they're challenged
but still changes in the epigenetic
landscape are
likely to bark and regulate the local
immune response
we hypothesize that the study of
epigenetic modification
is going to be one of the key factors to
be
considered so how did we study every
genetic
change and we used a tool called
epitope which is a basically a tool
to understand the physiologic landscape
a
profile that was originally reported by
trump echal
instead in 2017 to describe the
epigenetic changes in
age and then that was followed by
another publication
in 2018 and yet mind that
is that is a mathematically based
analytical
platform that simultaneously measures
epigenetics and immunological markers
at the single cell level honey this is
based on the availability of monoclonal
antibodies that can study
many of the epigenetic modifications
including
articulation ventilation phosphorylation
etc as well as non-compressive
modifications
including system variants and as you can
see
there are monoclonals that recognize
these epigenetic
changes in all of the history
system one two a two b system three and
system
four and they involve both methylation
and assassination
and all of the other signatures i just
described which are very clearly
illustrated in this a diagram
from a clinical immunology in the
2018 paper by chiang rai
so the overall strategy is to take
advantage of epidurals to create a cell
epigenetic atlas
in cells isolated from the human
feminine healing
following in vitro exposure to white
like salmonella diet
by using this high dimensional analysis
using disney classroom and other modern
tools and a some
other even a more advanced rule
developed by
astrolabe although these were not used
in the presence that is we are
collaborating with them in trying to
understand this phenomenon
in fact that did them we compare and
cause
consciously the chromatin modification
between and within the different
sometimes following exposure
to dive and this is a critical
issue because it's master geometry
we were able to connect 8 to 10 million
individual cells for each volunteer
in each experiment to assure the
sufficient number
of events would be analyzed for each of
the cells
faster and for each of the epigenetic
modifications
so the experimental design of this study
it involves two stages the first stage
of the exhalation of the
preservation of epithelial and cells
for this the the tissues from the
feminine healing we are disapplicated
and and injected with collagen spores is
based on dna
we generate distinction suspensions
which were filtered and cryopreserved in
liquid nitrogen
until we were ready to run the
on the day of infections we saw the
smells we incubate them for two hours
and then we expose them or not to one
sex harmonella
type and this allowed us to compare
directly
those epigenetic modifications in the
presence
for absence of salmonella driving
and after the inclination we use a panel
of 33 metal label monofilament
antibodies and analyze the data by mass
hydrogen
a pov is a panel of 3 a
metal that includes a
so multiple subsets
but we tested eleven major cell subsets
including b cells cd3 positive thesis
or cpa and ktc akama delta
made which are the methods associated
with valiant diesel
nkt monocyte macrophages and epithelium
cells so a mass economically allowed us
to study all of these subsets
congratulations
with the expression of six classes of
system modifications
and one is on a body
here and i am a showing the
supervised clustering of epigenetic
changes
between and within the different
universal
cell subjects after typing fraction and
you
can see how media
and dy2 have different existing values
and that each cell subject in this
species being distracted before they
describe cpa
in this case epithelial cells have
very different ah these lymphatics
so with a color code
the location of the epigenetic marked
meta clusters and this is what we see
here
so we could study these
populations in further
in this slide i am showing the
unsupervised clustering
of the epigenetic changes associated
with exposure to salmonella typhin
and from the 225 cluster
that we identified the data was grouped
into 15
meter cluster and organized based on
their similarities in high-dimensional
space and this were a performance type
were performed using
the class of algorithm and size apart
and these are of course a identification
increase with nodes at the same
sides now when we look at the chromatin
changes initiative by salmonella
inflation we can
see that in certain
epigenetic marks we see increased
expression for example
in in this case the acetylation
of the lysine in the
h2p system
and so on we have several
that have increased expression and
several
of the epigenetic marks in which
the difference between a type infected
and non-effective
actually was negative
so when we look at the meta cluster
mass of the mucosal subset abundance
and this is called all 11 success
that we studied we can see
in the pipe chart that
those that were incubated with media
and those that were incubated with dy2
were
clearly a different in terms of the
epigenetic
modifications but if i look at this area
and compare in the presence of
salmonella diet
versus the same area in the absence of
salmonella type
and we are
continuing this study by looking into
further details are displayed
differences in the absence for the
presence of salmonella types
now the other advantages of mass
psychometry is that
it allows us to study the
multi-functional
patterns of epigenetic changes in the
various microscopes
and as you can see there was a very
significant
difference between the chromatin marker
that are decreased on those that are
increased in the presence of salmonella
type
but since we have all of the labels
in the same cube we could
gain from for example db for positive
pixels in this slide and
we can see that there is a significant
increase in arginine methylation
in 34 positive clouds following exposure
to salmonella titanium
also we could into further
detail by looking at silicon positive
cells
which have over expression of the
argument methylation
position 2 and a would
associate this a changes in these cells
with
functionality and in this case
in the left panel we can see that the
ear vector memory cells
are significantly over represented
inserts that are creating on a
precision argument calculation two c
before positive
data and interestingly enough
they are significantly decreased for the
expression of
cd 57 which is a very important
maturation marker
if we go one step there is further in
this multi-functional analysis
and we do hierarchical clustering of
silicon processing itself
this was a using physical component
analysis
we can see when we
grow by media or exposure
to salmonella dieting different
increases that
argument methylation is a major driver
as we discussed
before but argument methylation
sometimes is a combined
in certain structure with other
epigenetic
marks that does overexpress or
underexpress
simultaneously and this is a story that
is
just starting but it is a little
in into further in the study of the
epigenetic
landscape so in conclusion
is infection does indeed result in
epigenetic modifications that are
centric
and substance specific this includes
multiple epigenetic modification
including the methylation of
histogram three of machine four system
foreign
association in some cases an
arginine methylation as well
these epigenetic marks have already been
shown to affect differentiation
in other systems so we are
assuming that they are likely to also
have a major effect in decent
differentiation and
gene expression following exposure to
salmonella
tyson and this
might be important among other things
because for example
arginine methylation controls the
strength of
the self signaling via the gamma chain a
family of cytokines which includes
two values
so the overall conclusion
is that the understanding the absence of
the epigenetic
regulator which determines the finding
transcription
a pattern different attacks
and something is essential in
intellectualizing the batteries
associated with protection from
infection
as well as those that will result in the
development of robust and effective
crosstinian responses
these studies as group of foreign
that these epigenetic changes in mucosal
cells
isolate it from the human terminal ilium
can be directly linked to exposure
to a gut pathogen which is a major
source of disease
and a future studies are needed to
really
further get into these responses
establish temporal patterns and
immediately and i would like to
acknowledge
los angeles to perform studies
assisted by the entire chain of regina
harvey
as well as andrea barford the surgeon
who may
provide us with the technical
issues of course themselves of support
and with that i would like to thank you
very much for your attention
thank you dr stein for your informative
presentation
we'll now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click the ask a question box
located at the far left of your screen
let's get started our first question
is why is it important to study the
difference
between immunity and children and adults
well i say most of the audience knows
the children respond differently
than adults and in a case in which
we are studying a responses to
vaccination
it's very important to know what are the
difference between the
new responses in the children
than in adults because that can be
markedly
influenced not only the effectiveness of
the vaccine
but also can they have a marked effect
on the duration and the quality of the
response
the reason why i brought the example of
children
versus adults is because by
a studying those differences
hopefully we can understand whether the
mechanisms of protection
are the same in children and in adults
and what are
the specific determinants of the
characteristics of the populations
that we can a study
to a define how the vaccines
are expected to
work in children versus adults or
the elderly for that matter because
there are many
associated differences with the aging
that are also very important for a
vaccine that are directed to the
development population
awesome um just a follow-up question to
that is um
there have been several efforts to
obtain global immune maps
of healthy immune systems in adults
is there any such effort underway for
children that you're aware of
unfortunately and i might be wrong but i
am not aware of
any a similar efforts that are
under way in children
definitively it's a very good question
and something that they
should be explored given the importance
of the relative
differences between children adults and
their elderly
and i will say probably among all ages
rather thank you
um and it looks like we have a couple
questions coming in from the audience
thank you
um one of them is uh
is the epigenetic changes been
looked at in a in functional assays
no but that's another excellent question
and that is a what is coming
next and the reason is
that's why i mentioned at the outset of
that component of the presentation
that this is almost like a proof of
principle
in infectious diseases is a field
a lot of work remains to be done and
studying at the
functional implications of the
epigenetic modifications that we have
seen after exposing the cells
to wide-type salmonella typhi is very
high on the agenda
thank you um and it looks like we have
another question
from the audience here can you comment
on the effect
of the adjuvants excuse me if i
mispronounced that in a vaccine in
adults versus children
does that account for these differences
to some level
well these are all very very good
questions the question of the
arguments is particularly important
because some of the proposed mechanisms
of a juventus is
through a regulation at the level of
epigenetics
so to my knowledge
that was never studied in
a human with cells isolated
from tissues like for example terminal
ilium data present
so that's definitely an avenue that has
to be
explored in the adjuvant field thank you
for that question great thank you
um off the topic of of children but
uh just going into uh
cytometry um are there any other
examples in humans
other than salmina salmonema
cytometry has been used to study human
challenges
uh yes i didn't go into
some of those performed in my group
because of a
lack of time but we have studied
a model in which enterotoxygenic we call
like wild type
was used to challenge volunteers and
in those studies we also studied
the responses using mass cytometry
and as a matter of fact we identified
very interesting correlations
between 18 follicular helper cells
and they are expression of intervene
alpha 4 beta 7 which is
a mucosal homing markers and for example
if the level of a diarrhea that
in terms of volume in volunteers
who have been challenged with effect
intratoxogenic ecoli some of whom were
protected
and some of whom were not
so there are other infections in which
this can be studied and i think is a
it is a very very important avenue to
pursue
given the fact that a
in human challenge model
we are as close as we can get into real
life
thank you um and it looks like we have
about
one minute left so i'm just going to ask
one more question here
do you envision epitoph to become a
valuable application
for siteof users and if so
what is needed to make this a more
accessible application for saitaf users
i think that it is going to be a very
important foresight of users and the
reason i say
that is that this is a technology that
can
allow the concomitant measurements of
many many epigenetic modifications
in many cell subsets at the same time
but instead of collecting just a few
hundred cells
because of course for example in these
studies
we collected about eight or ten million
cells for example so the
data that we obtained and the other
groups
might obtain there are millions of
individual cells measuring of course
up to 50 plus parameters so
my expectation is as time
day goes by more
research group will look into this
technique
as a possible forefront application of
mass economic
i guess only time will tell yeah
right well thank you so much for your
time today and so much for all your
important research
um we really appreciate hearing from you
um before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and
questions submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed
by the speaker via contact information
provided at the time of registration
uh this webcast can be viewed on demand
just give it a give it a day or so and
you can
review the presentation here today until
next time
goodbye thank you very much